I like the way you're thinking I don't
really care about the music
[Music]
hi I'm computer engineer Barbie other
words for me include software engineer
software developer they all pretty much
mean the same thing more on that later I
love starting my day reading some tech
news it allows me to just wake up my
brain without getting into anything too
heavy some things in store for us today
include a meeting with some team members
that'll be fun and then I'm gonna do
some coding for this game I've been
developing I'm so excited
[Music]
[Applause]
okay awesome I feel really ready to get
started first let's talk about what it
means to be a software engineer well
simply put software engineering is the
practice of writing maintaining
designing software you know apps on your
smartphone like Instagram and Tick Tock
or video games like fortnite and
Minecraft yes those are all built by
software Engineers I specifically love
talking about games because that's the
type of software engineering I do now
software engineering doesn't have to be
this huge thing like creating a whole
game or a whole app even your more basic
sites are built by software Engineers so
the skills are required to be a software
engineer other than knowing programming
languages well problem solving is vital
if you like Puzzles or find yourself
just excited to saw of new things this
may be the uh the career for you
communication is another huge skill for
this field because you're going to see
very soon and I think it's actually
going to be in just a couple minutes so
hold on you're gonna see how much
working as a team is important to get
things done on the job okay let's run
over and set up for a meeting because I
think they might be waiting for us hi
Ken hi Ken hi Ken hi Ken hi Ken hi Ken
there's a lot of cans in this meeting
and on the team that's another thing to
note about software engineering there
are a lot of cans around it is very male
dominated but hey I'm really fortunate
to be on a team that welcomes me and all
of my ideas
[Music]
Ken's I'm thinking of adding a new trick
for the doggy game I'd like to swap out
the doggy sit for a twirl what do we
think team meetings are necessary for
making sure everyone fully understands
what responsibilities they have and it
also allows them to ask questions and
ask for help don't ever be afraid to ask
for help great have a great weekend bye
Kens okay great I am so excited to get
coding on this new project I'm so close
to getting it done and I really hope
it's done today so ah fingers crossed in
fact let me show you what that project
is I'm building a puppy game where you
are instructed you as the user are
instructed to make the dog do tricks and
there's some blocks and a timer and it's
all very fascinating I can't wait to
show you but first I uh I have some bugs
to fix so let's do that
[Music]
oh my goodness it works and I am so
excited let me show you what it does
ready to see the game so this is a spin
on that memory card game that I used to
love as a kid the screen tells you what
tricks it wants the doggy to do so that
could be jump
plural or roll the player has one minute
60 seconds to get as many right as
possible and just keep getting better
and better playing the game
[Music]
foreign I love testing things like my
memory and just waking my brain up so I
thought this was a fun cute way to do
that
software engineering can be hard but
honestly it's so rewarding getting to
end the day like this seeing my game
come to life and knowing that I tackled
every problem that came my way all of
course with some help from my team some
resources around me but yeah I'm so so
happy with it are you happy with it
thank you so much for going to the day
with me it was so much fun having you
around and I'll see you very soon
hopefully in a team meeting bye